What do the founders and leaders of Tesla,
YouTube, and LinkedIn have in common?
They all started their early careers at PayPal,
the online payment company.
This group of highly ambitious twenty and
thirty-year-olds has been dubbed the “PayPal
mafia” and once even dressed up as mafia
members for the cover of Fortune magazine.
They went on to found or run some of the largest
tech companies in the world.
Elon Musk was absent the day of the shoot
because of a scheduling conflict.
This is by no means all of them.
Peter Thiel estimates
that the “mafia” is around 220 people.
Thiel is a famous start-up investor
often referred to as the “don” of the
PayPal mafia.
PayPal began when Thiel and Max Levchin created
software company Confinity as a way to transfer
money through the once-popular Palm Pilot.
Confinity then merged with Elon Musk’s payment
company x.com, to become PayPal in 2000.
Musk briefly served as CEO before being kicked
out in favor of Thiel who took over until
eBay bought PayPal in 2002 for $1.5 billion dollars.
It was partly eBay’s doing for making
these entrepreneurs so successful.
When eBay bought PayPal, many of the PayPal
employees left because they had difficulty
adjusting to the traditional corporate culture
at eBay.
Within four years, only 12 of the first 50
PayPal employees remained.
The rest took their entrepreneurial skills
to make the next great thing.
And because they were friends they could lean
on each other to build new companies.
Thiel and Levchin made a habit of hiring people
they liked.
Thiel recruited a bunch of Stanford
grads who attended around
the same time as him.
Levchin scouted developers and former classmates
from his alma mater, the University of Illinois
Urbana-Champaign.
Levchin once asked a guy in an interview what
he liked to do for fun.
He responded: play hoops.
Levchin decided not to hire him because he
said everyone he knew in college who played
basketball was an idiot.
They weeded out the jocks, frat members, and
those with MBAs.
Instead, they hired people like themselves.
Levchin described the ideal candidate:
“He thinks like me, he’s just as geeky,
and he doesn’t get laid very often.
Great hire!
We’ll get along perfectly.”
And very importantly, they hired workaholics.
A start-up involves long hours and a lot
of pressure, but not a lot of sleep.
The pace at PayPal was so intense that employees
didn’t have a life outside of work.
They were each others' social life.
Most of the friends who showed up to Levchin’s
29th birthday at an upscale Vietnamese restaurant
in San Francisco were former PayPal colleagues.
At one point the conversation turned to how
hard it was to find a good dentist.
That got Jeremy Stoppelman, a former VP of
engineering at PayPal, and Russel Simmons,
one of the brilliant engineers behind PayPal,
talking about a website where people could
review services.
They would go on to found Yelp.
The problems they solved at PayPal served
them well as they built their own companies.
They had to figure out how to stop PayPal
from losing millions of dollars each month.
They had to deal with fraud, stiff competition
from credit card companies as well as eBay’s
own payment system.
As Reid Hoffman, a former executive vice-president
at PayPal put it: “Nothing focuses your
attention quite like losing money.”
And focus was the name of the game.
Former PayPal executive Keith Rabois explained
on the question and answer site Quora that
PayPal was driven by the “extreme focus”
of each individual on a single task.
There was great emphasis on individual accomplishment
and as a result, COO David Sacks wasn’t
a fan of big meetings.
This is something Elon Musk has taken
to heart as CEO of Tesla.
He reportedly sent an email to Tesla employees
saying large meetings are a waste of time.
And people are free to walk out of one or
drop off a call if they’re not adding anything
of value.
Musk took his $180 million in PayPal earnings
from the eBay sale to become one of the major
funders of Tesla while also
starting his rocket company SpaceX.
Others put their money into supporting
startups by PayPal alumni.
That’s how YouTube began.
Three former PayPal employees came up with
the idea for a video sharing platform when
they couldn’t find any videos of the famous
Superbowl halftime incident involving
Justin Timberlake and Janet Jackson in 2004.
Chad Hurley designed the logo
and look of YouTube.
Steve Chen made sure it worked.
And Jawed Karim helped with both the design
and the programming.
Karim uploaded the first-ever video to YouTube,
“Me at the zoo”, on April 23, 2005 which
now has almost 200 million views!
But the bond between three PayPal bros wasn’t
enough to make YouTube successful.
They needed financial backing.
And that’s where their PayPal connections
came in handy.
While at a backyard BBQ, Karim showed the
site to his friend, Rabois, the former PayPal
executive.
Rabois later told PayPal’s former chief
financial officer, Roelof Bathoa, about it.
Bathoa is a partner at Sequoia Capital,
a venture capital firm that has backed big
names like Apple and Google.
Botha then got Sequoia to invest in YouTube.
Some PayPal executives went on to become prolific
angel investors, like Hoffman.
If you wanted to start a company, this was
the guy to know.
He reportedly arranged the first meeting between
Thiel and Mark Zuckerberg which led Thiel
to smartly invest half a million dollars into
Facebook in return for a 10% stake.
Thiel would walk away with more than $1 billion
dollars.
There were few investors looking to write
cheques at the time.
The dot-com bubble of the late nineties destroyed
the dreams of many when it burst in the early
2000s.
There was even talk in Silicon Valley that
consumer tech might be dead.
PayPal was one of the few start-ups to survive
the crash.
And not only survive but thrive
which goes to show how important
networking and surrounding yourself with the
right people really are.
The PayPal mafia went on to create seven “unicorn”
companies - privately held start-ups valued
at over $1 billion.
There’s another unicorn I haven’t mentioned
yet which brings me to the sponsor of my video,
Masterworks.
Imagine if you could own a Monet or a Warhol
- usually reserved for the uber-rich.
Well, Masterworks allows you to buy shares
in high-end art - just like buying shares
of any stock.
Masterworks acquires multi-million-dollar
artworks from the best artists and allows
you and me to invest in these masterpieces
that have been securitized by the SEC.
When Masterworks sells the art or if you sell
your shares to other members on their secondary
market, the rewards could be enormous.
Those who invested in Banksy’s Mona Lisa
saw a 32% net return on their investment after
just a year.
And fine art is only going up in value - appreciating
14% a year from 1995 to 2020 - even outperforming
the S&P 500.
Plus, art doesn’t generally react to market
volatility in the same way that other assets
do.
If you’d like to join over 250,000 people
who have already signed up for Masterworks,
you can head to the custom link in my description.
And in just a few minutes, you're on your
way to diversifying your portfolio with one
of the most stable assets around.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.